if your training set comes from a
different distribution than your Devon
test set and if error analysis shows you
that you have a data mismatch problem
what can you do
there aren't completely systematic
solutions to this but let's look at some
things you could try if I find out I
have a large data mismatch problem what
I usually do is carry out manual error
analysis and try to understand the
differences between the training set in
the dev test set to avoid overfitting
the tensor technically for error
analysis you should manually only look
at the depth set and order the test set
but as a concrete example if you're
building the speech activated rearview
mirror application you might look or I
guess of the speech listen to examples
in your jet set to try to figure out how
your def set is different than your
training set so for example you might
find that a lot of deaths of examples
are very noisy and there's a lot of car
noise and this is one way that your def
set differs from your training set and
maybe you'll find other categories of
errors for example in the speech
activated rearview mirror in your car
you might find that there's often miss
recognizing street numbers because there
are a lot more navigational queries
which will have street address so
getting three numbers right is really
important when you have insight into the
nature of the DEF set errors so we have
insight into how the jet set may be
different or harder than your training
set what you can do is then try to find
ways to make the training data more
similar or alternatively try to collect
more data similar to your dev and test
sense so for example if you find that
car noise in the background is a major
source of error one thing you could do
is simulate noisy in car data say a
little bit more about how to do this on
the next slide or if you find that
you're having a hard time recognizing
street numbers maybe you can go and
deliberately try to get more data of
people speaking out numbers
and add that to your training set now I
realize that this slide is giving a
rough guideline for things you could try
this isn't a systematic process and I
guess there's no guarantee that you get
the in size you need to make progress
but I found that this manual insight
together we're trying to make the data
more similar on the dimensions that
matter the dissolve it helps on a lot of
problems so if your goal is to make the
training data more similar to your def
set what are some things you can do one
of the techniques you can use is
artificial data synthesis and let's
discuss that in the context of
addressing the Conway's problem so to
build a speech recognition system maybe
you don't have a lot of audio that was
actually recorded inside a car with the
background noise of a car back on the
highway and so on but it turns out
there's a way to synthesize it so let's
say that you've recorded a large amount
of clean audio without this car
background noise so here's an example of
a clip you might have in your training
set by the way this sentence is use a
lot in AI for testing because this is a
short sentence that contains every
alphabet from A to Z so you see this
sentence a lot but given that recording
of the quick brown fox jumps over the
lazy dog
you can then also get a recording of car
noise like this so that's what the
inside of car sounds like I could be
driving in silence and if you take these
two audio clips and add them together
you can then synthesize what saying the
quick brown fox jumps our lazy dog would
sound like if you were saying that in a
noisy talk so it sounds like this so
this is a relatively simple audio
synthesis example in practice you might
synthesize other audio effects like the
perforation which is the sound of your
voice bouncing off the walls of the car
and so on but through artificial data
synthesis you might be able to quickly
create more data that sounds like it was
recorded inside the car without needing
to go out there and collect tons of data
maybe thousands or tens of thousands of
hours of data in a car that's actually
driving along so if your error analysis
shows you that you should try to make
your data sound more like it was
recorded inside a car then this could be
a reasonable process for synthesizing
that type of data to give you a turning
ro now there is one note of caution I
want to sound on artificial data
synthesis which is that let's say you
have 10,000 hours of data that was
recorded against a quiet background and
let's say that you have just one hour of
car noise so one thing you could try is
take this one hour of car noise and
repeat it 10,000 times in order to add
to this 10,000 hours of data recorded
against a quiet background if you do
that the audio will sound perfectly fine
to the human ear but there is a chance
there's a risk that your learning
algorithm will over fit to be one hour
of car noise and in particular if this
is a set of all
um audio that you can record in the car
or maybe the sets of all Conroy's
backgrounds you can imagine if you have
just one hour of car noise background
you might be simulating just a very
small subset of this space you might be
just synthesizing from a very small
subset of this space and to the human
ear all this audio sounds just fine
because one hour of car noise sounds
just like any other RF convoy to the
human ear but it's possible that you're
synthesizing data from a very small
subset of the space and the neural
network might be overfitting to the one
R of conyers that you have I don't know
if it'd be practically feasible to
inexpensively collect 10,000 hours of
car noise so that you don't need to
repeat the same one R of car noise over
and over but you have 10,000 unique odds
of car noise to add to $10,000 of unique
audio recording games a clean background
but it's possible not no guarantees but
it is possible that using 10,000 hours
of unique car noise rather than just one
R that could result in better
performance to your learning algorithm
and the challenge with artificial data
synthesis is to the human ear far as
your ears can tell these 10,000 hours
all sounds the same as this one are so
you might end up creating this very
impoverished synthesized data set from a
much sort of subset in the space without
actually realizing it just another
example of artificial data synthesis
let's say you're building a so driving
car and so you want to really to check
vehicles like this and you know put a
bounding box around it Leslie so one
idea that a lot of people have discussed
is well once you use computer graphics
to simulate tons of images of cars and
the fact here are a couple pictures of
cars that were generated using computer
graphics
now these graphics effects is actually
pretty good and you can imagine that by
synthesizing rachels ideas you could
train a pretty good computer vision
system for detecting caused
unfortunately the picture that I drew on
the previous line again applies in this
setting maybe this is the set of all
cars and if you synthesize just a very
small subset of these cause then to the
human eye
maybe the synthesized images look fine
but you might over fit to this small
subset you're synthesizing in particular
one idea that a lot of people have
independently raises once you find a
video game where could computer graphics
and cars and just grab images from them
and get a huge data set of pictures of
course it turns out that if you look at
a video game if the video game has just
20 unique calls in a video game then the
video game looks fine because you're
driving around in the video game when
you see these twenty other calls and you
know looks like a pretty realistic
simulation but the world has a lot more
than 20 unique designs of calls and the
entire synthesized training set has only
20 distinct calls then your neural
network will probably over fit to these
20 cars and it's difficult for a person
to you easily tell that even though
these images look realistic
you're really covering such a tiny
subset of the set of all possible cause
so to summarize if you think you have a
data mismatch problem I recommend you do
error analysis or look at a training set
that will go to death set to try this
figure out try to gain insight into how
these two distributions of data might
differ and then see if you can find some
ways to get more training data there
looks a bit more like your death set one
of the ways you talked about is
artificial data synthesis and artificial
data synthesis does work in speech
recognition I've seen artificial data
synthesis significantly boost the
performance of what we're already very
good speech recognition systems so it
can work very well but if you're using
artificial instances just be cautious
and bear in mind whether or not you
might be accidentally simulating data
only from a tiny subset of the space of
all possible examples so that's it for
how to deal with data mismatch
NIC's I'd like to share you some
thoughts on how to learn from multiple
types of data at the same time